Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und nach einer kürzeren Pause über Weihnachten nehmen wir jetzt hier die Senderei wieder auf und steigen mit dem mittlerweile 31. Gespräch hier ein. Und für diese Ausgabe hat mich der Weg nach Braunschweig geführt an einen weiteren Standort des DLR. Und heute geht es mal nicht direkt um Raumfahrt, sondern eher ein begleitendes Programm, was in gewisser Hinsicht auch als Vorbereitung für Raumfahrtaktivitäten gesehen werden könnte. Aber zunächst einmal ganz andere Ziele hat. Konkret geht es um die DLR Schoollabs und um darüber Auskunft zu erhalten, begrüße ich Anke Kowa.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, hab schon gesagt, wir sind hier in Braunschweig, einer von vielen DLR Standorten in Deutschland. Hier sind die DLR Schoollabs und du bist die Leiterin des DLR Schoollabs hier eben in Braunschweig. Wie lange bist du schon hier?
Also hier in Braunschweig bin ich jetzt seit ziemlich genau drei Jahren insgesamt beim DLR, jetzt schon seit elf. Ich habe angefangen in Göttingen, dort noch mit der Wissenschaft befasst, in einer sogenannten Hochgeschwindigkeitserodynamik und jetzt seit drei Jahren, wie gesagt, widme ich mich der Nachwuchsförderung.
Und über welchen Ausbildungsweg bist du überhaupt zum DLR so gekommen?
Eigentlich bin ich hier ein klassischer Seiteneinsteiger, das heißt, ich habe mein Abitur gemacht, ganz normal, habe danach auch eigentlich erst mal vom Lernen mehr oder weniger die Nase voll gehabt, habe demzufolge erstmal eine Ausbildung gemacht im kaufmännischen Bereich, ich bin also auch gelernte Außenhandelskauffrau und dann allerdings kam die Erkenntnis während der Ausbildung wiederum relativ schnell, dass das irgendwie noch nicht alles gewesen sein kann und habe dann überlegt, wie ich da jetzt weitermache und bin eigentlich über das Ausschlussprinzip dann letztendlich bei den Geowissenschaften gelandet, das heißt, ich habe Meteorologie studiert, Physik der Atmosphäre und da ich mich aber dann eben mit meiner Abschlussarbeit Wenn ich mich an die DLR-Schoolsarbeit mit der Strömungsmechanik befasst hab, das war dann sozusagen die Brücke und das Ticket hier zum DLR.
In Göttingen dann zunächst einmal. Dann von Göttingen direkt nach Braunschweig weiter.
Ja, genau.
Ja, DLR-Schoollabs, was verbirgt sich denn dahinter, grob mal zusammengefasst?
Die DLR-Schoollabs sind eine Einrichtung des DLR, wo wir Schülernachwuchsförderung betreiben. Das heißt, wir haben an neun Standorten bzw. an sieben Standorten und zwei TUs, also technischen Universitäten, Labore aufgebaut, in denen Schülerinnen und Schüler selbstständig experimentieren können. Und somit eigentlich mal so ein bisschen über den Tellerrand rausgucken können, gucken können, was gibt es denn noch neben den klassischen Berufen und vor allen Dingen eben auch so ein bisschen das, was sie in der Schule gelernt haben, mit Leben füllen können und feststellen können, dass man das, was man in der Schule lernt, wirklich braucht.
Also zur Klarstellung, Schoollabs bezieht sich wirklich auf Schule. Schüler, das sind diejenigen, die jetzt hier primär angesprochen werden, aber das hier halt integriert in diesen Standort. Wofür steht der DLR-Standort in Braunschweig insgesamt?
Der DLR-Standort in Braunschweig steht für Luftfahrt und Verkehr. Und Verkehr an dieser Stelle auch der bodengebundene Verkehr, also sprich Kraftfahrzeuge und Schienenfahrzeuge. Und eben der zweite Schwerpunkt ist hier die Luftfahrt. Ja genau, das ist unser Forschungsflughafen. Und wir alle lieben das hier auch ab und an immer mal, die Flugzeuge landen und starten zu sehen und das Kerosin zu riechen. Und das hält uns glaube ich hier alle ein bisschen am Leben. Ich glaube, ich sage immer, wir sind alle hier mit ein Stück weit Kerosin-Junkies. Aber es motiviert natürlich auch wahnsinnig, wenn man in so einer Umgebung hier Forschung betreiben kann oder eben auch jetzt mit der Nachwuchsförderung da arbeiten kann.
Aber es ist jetzt kein normaler Flugplatz hier. Das ist explizit als Forschungsflugplatz ausgewiesen. Was heißt das? Wird der jetzt hier ausschließlich vom DLR bespielt?
Also nicht ganz ausschließlich. Wir haben hier insgesamt, ich glaube fünf Anteilseigner, ich will jetzt nichts Falsches sagen. Einer davon ist auch VW, aber wir sind halt ein großer, weiterer Anteilseigner davon. Der Forschungsflughafen wird eben auch in dem Falle als Forschungsflughafen benutzt. Er wird nicht ausgebaut werden, das wird also nie jetzt irgendwie ein Ferienflughafen werden oder so was. Sondern der wird hier wirklich benutzt, damit wir Forschung betreiben können. Das heißt, unsere Forschungsflugzeuge aus unserer Flotte, also teilweise Flugzeuge, teilweise Helikopter, werden hier eingesetzt, von hier losgeflogen, um Untersuchungen durchzuführen. Beziehungsweise, wir haben so zwei Gattungen an Forschungsflugzeugen. Das ist so ganz spannend. In Oberpfaffenhofen steht die eine Hälfte, hier bei uns im Braunschweig die zweite.
Also geht es um Flugzeuge, um damit Forschung zu machen? Oder um an Flugzeugen Forschung zu machen?
Genau, das ist nämlich genau der interessante oder der spannende Unterschied. In Oberpfaffenhofen, die Flugzeuge dienen im Grunde dazu, Messgeräte irgendwo hinzubringen, um dort Untersuchungen durchzuführen, wie zum Beispiel jetzt mit der Falcon oder dem Ash Hunter. Das ist vielleicht bekannt geworden, als jetzt der Aya Fjella in Island ausgebrochen ist. Der Vulkan, da sind wir mit der Falcon-Halter hingeflogen, um Untersuchungen dann zu machen. Wo sind jetzt die Aschewolken, in welcher Höhe, mit welcher Partikelgröße, wie sind die beschaffen, wie heiß ist das dort drin. Das waren alles Untersuchungen, die die Falcon gemacht hat. Hier bei uns in Braunschweig die Flugzeuge.
Hatten wir übrigens auch hier das Thema schon bei Raumzeit besprochen in einem interessanten Podcast mit die Atmosphäre.
Und hier in Braunschweig unsere Flugzeuge werden dazu eingesetzt. An denen findet die Forschung quasi selbst statt. Also das heißt, wir benutzen unseren ATAS beispielsweise, um Wirbelschleppen zu erforschen oder sogenannte Hochauftriebssysteme zu untersuchen. Das heißt, das sind eben bestimmte Systeme, die man benötigt, zum Beispiel bei der Landung, um besonders viel Auftrieb zu erzeugen. Und insofern sind das so ein bisschen die Unterschiede an den Flugzeugen, die wir hier haben.
Um das vielleicht mit dem Standort nochmal hier so vollständig zu verstehen, was für Institute sind jetzt hier konkret angesiedelt?
Wir haben hier vor Ort sechs Institute. Das eine ist das Institut für Aerodynamik und Strömungstechnik. Die befassen sich im Wesentlichen mit der Umströmung von Flugzeugen, der Lärmproblematik, Treibstoffreduktion, Widerstandsreduktion. Das sind deren Hauptaufgaben. Dann haben wir das Institut für Faserverbundleichtbau und Adaptronik. Die machen zum einen die Erforschung von CFK, GFK, also Kohlefaser und glasfaserverstärkte Kohlenstoffe, die letztendlich eine wichtige Rolle spielen im Flugzeugbau, weil man immer mehr Teile des Flugzeugs ersetzt gegen besonders leichte Materialien, die aber genauso widerstandsfähig und fest sein müssen, wie vorher das Flugzeughörnium. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Findet hier am Ort Raumfahrtbezogen weniger statt, aber ist natürlich ein wichtiges Thema. Dann haben wir hier das Institut für Verkehrssystemtechnik. Die befassen sich eben mit der Weiterentwicklung der Forschung von Fahrerassistenzsystemen im Kfz-Bereich. Bei den Fahrerassistenzsystemen, die haben ja ihren Weg gefunden aus der Luftfahrt, als Ableitung aus den Autopiloten. Und auch hier geht es eben darum, wie kann man dem Fahrer seine Fahrt leichter machen oder sicherer machen oder eben Aufgaben abnehmen. Das ist eigentlich der Hintergrund. Technisch kann man sich alles Mögliche vorstellen, aber die Frage ist ja auch immer, hilft es dem Fahrer denn wirklich? Ich kann mir ja vorstellen, ich kann das Cockpit zupflastern mit Anzeigen und Displays und Informationen, die ich abrufen kann, aber kann ich das denn wirklich alles noch aufnehmen und verarbeiten? Oder stört es mich und hält es mich von einer eigentlichen Aufgabe ab? Nämlich der, dass ich einfach Auto fahren will.
Also über die Technik hinaus wird auch die Anwendbarkeit untersucht?
Genau. Das ist auch das, womit man eigentlich selten rechnet bei uns. Also hier im Institut arbeiten eben auch eine ganze Reihe von Psychologen. Genauso auch im Institut für Flugführung. Da ist es das Gleiche, im Grunde die untersuchen oder erforschen Piloten- und Lotsenassistenzsysteme. Und da ist eben die gleiche Frage, also wie kann man halt eben den Menschen die Aufgabe erleichtern? Wie kann man das sicherer machen, insbesondere in der Luftfahrt? Wir haben alle noch bestimmte Geschichten im Kopf, wie damals zum Beispiel in Überlingen, wo ein Lotse Dienst hatte, und dann kam in einer Nacht lediglich drei Flugzeuge vorbei, eins etwas weiter weg, aber zwei haben sich dann halt ja ungünstigerweise im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes getroffen. Und da ist halt eben die Frage, wie kann man das verhindern? Und da sind eben damals, gut, das war eine Verkettung von sehr vielen, sehr unglücklichen Umständen, aber man nimmt sowas natürlich immer als Anlass, um hinterher die Systeme wieder zu verbessern und dem Menschen einfach zu helfen. Oder ihn zu unterstützen.
2002 war das.
Und dann haben wir noch das Institut für Flugsystemtechnik. Die beschäftigen sich auch mit Helikoptern und auch den unbemannten Flugobjekten. Auch den unbekannten Flugobjekten? Erst sind sie unbekannt, dann sind sie unbemannt. Genau, in Deutschland. Die befassen sich letztendlich mit Drohnen. Unbemannte Fluggeräte, die man zur Aufklärung einsetzen kann. Oder wenn man Gebiete hat, wo man gerade nicht rankommt, sei es Sandsturm oder Vulkanausbruch oder wie auch immer. Wenn man dabei Informationen darüber erfahren möchte, dann kann man solche Geräte einsetzen. Das ist eine sehr spannende Aufgabe, diese autonom fliegenden Geräte wirklich sicher irgendwo hinzubekommen, Informationen zu bekommen, die zu übertragen, die Geräte wieder zurückzubekommen. Das kostet ja auch ein bisschen was. Das möchte man ja schon gern wieder haben. Das ist eine Aufgabe. Und dann haben wir, glaube ich, noch zu guter Letzt das Institut für Flugverkehrswesen und Luftverkehr. Nee, Flughafenwesen und Luftverkehr. Das ist unser neustes Institut. Deswegen geht mir das noch nicht so ganz von den Lippen. Das ist jetzt neu dazugekommen. Die beschäftigen sich mit Passagierströmen und Frachtströmen. Also wir kennen das alle von Flughafen. Oder von Flugzeugen generell. Wir haben einmal die Passagiere, wir haben die Fracht, wir haben das Gepäck und alles unterliegt einer gewissen Logistik. Da geht es darum zu gucken, wie kann man das optimieren? Wie kann man Notfallpläne schaffen? Wie stellt man sicher, dass Menschen sicher bei Notfällen in Gebäude nicht so sehr aber wieder rauskommen? Wie stellt man sicher, dass jeder am Ende das Gepäckstück wieder mitnimmt, was er dann auch am Anfang abgegeben hat? Oder es gibt einfach eine Erforschung dessen, wie ist denn jetzt der optimale Weg am schnellsten raus aus dem Flugzeug, wenn man gelandet ist? Jeder kennt das. Man ist gelandet und man will eigentlich nur raus. Und dann gibt es eben auch Untersuchungen, die aber auch zeigen, dass das tatsächlich der schnellste Weg ist.
Wobei man mittlerweile nicht mehr das Gefühl hat, dass das immer so im Vordergrund steht, weil man erstmal durch mehrere Supermärkte durchgeführt wird, bevor man raus darf. Okay, das sind also jetzt hier die sechs Institute, die allerlei Überlappungen haben, aber nicht nur. Das spielt aber jetzt auch in die Arbeit des School Labs mit rein. Das School Labs sind sozusagen jetzt kein eigenes Institut in dem Sinne, sondern ist mehr oder weniger an alles angegliedert. Verstehst du das richtig?
Also wir sind schon letztendlich eigenständige Einrichtungen, aber in der Tat, jedes School Lab hat die Aufgabe, die Versuche bzw. die Forschungseinrichtungen am Ort zu repräsentieren. Also das heißt, die Experimente, die wir halt im Labor aufgebaut haben für die Schulklassen, die uns besuchen, das sind letztendlich kleine Versionen von Versuchsständen aus den Instituten, die ich gerade beschrieben habe. Das heißt, wir haben halt eben auch bei uns wieder ein Fahrerassistenzsystem oder einen Stand zur Bahnsicherungstechnik oder einen Rotorversuchsstand oder einen Windkanal. Also alles das, was es hier eben auch vor Ort gibt. Und das macht das auch so besonders und so glaubwürdig, denke ich, weil wir halt wissen letztendlich, wovon wir reden.
Bevor wir vielleicht hier auf die Spezifika der School Labs hier in Braunschweig eingehen, muss man erst mal erwähnen, das ist natürlich nicht das einzige School Lab, was es gibt, sondern es gibt im DLR mehrere davon. Wie viele sind es?
Mittlerweile sind es neun. Das heißt, an sieben Standorten haben wir DLR School Labs und an zwei Standorten haben wir eine Kooperation mit technischen Universitäten. Das ist dann das DLR School Lab TU Dortmund und TU Hamburg.
Und bei den anderen ist es wie hier direkt auf irgendeinem DLR Gelände. Was ist denn jetzt das eigentliche Ziel, der eigentliche Hintergrund, dass es diese DLR School Labs gibt? Was für einen Bedarf wird hier abgedeckt? Was will man damit erreichen?
Wir versuchen, Nachwuchsförderung zu betreiben. Das ist ja immer das Schlagwort. Wir wissen alle momentan, dass es in Deutschland und nicht nur hier einen wahnsinnigen Nachwuchsmangel gibt. In den naturwissenschaftlichen, in den Ingenieurswissenschaftlichen Bereichen, auch im technischen Bereich. Und dass wir nicht annähernd die Stellen mehr besetzen können, die gebraucht werden momentan. Man liest so verschiedene Zahlen, aber letztes Jahr konnten zwischen 60.000 und 100.000 Ingenieursstellen nicht mehr besetzt werden in Deutschland, weil einfach der Nachwuchs fehlt. Und das DLR hat da tatsächlich versucht, an sehr früher Stelle schon zu reagieren. Das erste Labor ist im Jahr 2000 aufgebaut worden, in Göttingen damals. Und es ging damals halt eben schon darum, einfach Schüler zu interessieren für die Themen Luftfahrt, Raumfahrt, Verkehr. Um halt einfach die Jugend zu bewegen, wieder verstärkt in diese Bereiche reinzugucken. Und insofern versuchen wir halt, einfach Alternativen aufzuzeigen zu den Berufen, die man von zu Hause aus vielleicht kennt oder das, was man normalerweise auf dem Schirm hat.
Ist das jetzt einfach nur die Alterspyramide oder gibt es einen Mangel an Interesse an Wissenschaft?
Also es ist glaube ich eine Kombination aus beiden. Also ich meine, zum einen wissen wir, dass die Geburtenrate weiterhin rückläufig ist und dass wir da auf dem Sektor unseren Bedarf nicht decken sozusagen. Und zum anderen ist es auch, dass sich über die Jahre natürlich auch immer wieder neue Jobs etablieren. Und Jobs, die vielleicht auf den ersten Blick manchmal auch vielleicht etwas sexier wirken als jetzt gerade ein Ingenieur oder ein Naturwissenschaftler. Man verbindet damit ja auch immer was. Also es geht auch ganz häufig darum, dass uns Vorurteile blockieren. Man stellt sich halt den Physiker oder den Ingenieur immer als schlecht gekleideten Mann vor, der halt irgendwie auch ansonsten lebensunfähig ist, aber irgendwie ein Gen mehr im Kopf hat, was das Erfinden von irgendwelchen Sachen betrifft. Und ein Stück weit stimmt es manchmal vielleicht auch, aber das ist, glaube ich, viel zu kurz gegriffen. Und wir lassen uns aber sehr stark leiden davon. Also wenn man auch zum Beispiel in die PISA-Studie reinguckt, dann haben die dort schon festgestellt, dass uns diese Vorurteile weit mehr blockieren und weit mehr formen als aktuelle Fähigkeiten. Also das heißt Jugendliche, die eigentlich wirklich gut sind in diesem Bereich, wenn die aber glauben, dass Ingenieure und Physiker alles irgendwie ein bisschen, naja, geistig oder bzw. eben lebensunfähig sind sozusagen, dann prägt dir das mehr, als dass sie hinterher auf diese Fähigkeiten zurückgreifen und sagen, ich werd jetzt selber Physiker, weil das Vorbild irgendwie nicht da ist.
Das sind irgendwie nicht die Popstars.
Nee, ganz genau. Das ist überhaupt nicht hip. Und insofern ist das ein großes Problem, dass da sich sehr viel einfach in anderen Bereichen bewegt.
Und wie kann man das Problem denn angehen?
Wir versuchen das dadurch, dass wir die Schüler aktiv zu uns reinholen, dass wir sie experimentieren lassen, dass wir sie in Berührung bringen mit aktuellen Forschungsthemen, dass wir ihnen anbieten, in die Institute reinzugucken, dass wir uns die Teststände angucken, dass sie sehen können, dass ein Wissenschaftler im Grunde ein Mensch ist wie du und ich und dass das auch ein paar ganz coole Typen dabei gibt. Und versuchen halt einfach das Ganze mit Leben zu füllen.
Aber wen spricht man jetzt an?
Nee, das ist richtig. Aber in jeder Stadt gibt es sie überall. Und wir sprechen halt eben die Schüler an im Alter von 12 bis 19, sage ich mal. Also von Klasse 5 bis Klasse 13. Mittlerweile ja nur noch 12 in den meisten Fällen. Wir sprechen die Lehrer an. Also wir gehen deswegen halt eben auch auf zum Beispiel auf Messen, auf Ausstellungen. Wir nehmen an Aktionen der Stadt teil. Das ist so ein Punkt, was auch eben zu meinen Aufgaben hier gehört. Einfach eine Vernetzung in der Region herzustellen, sodass halt eben die Schülerinnen und Schüler, die Lehrer, dass die halt eben wirklich Kenntnis von uns haben und dann halt eben auch hierher kommen.
Das heißt, der Weg geht primär erstmal über die Schulen? Spricht man die Schulen direkt an? Also ich frage mich halt, wie entsteht diese Kooperation und wie groß ist da das Echo auch bei den Schulen selbst?
Also das Echo ist auf jeden Fall da. Also ich meine, wir sind jetzt mit unserem Labor, wir sind ja noch eins der jüngsten. Das heißt, uns gibt es jetzt seit November 2009. Wir sind jetzt zwei Jahre hier gerade am Start. Und wir haben einen Vorlauf von ungefähr drei bis vier Monaten. Also das heißt, wenn du uns jetzt anrufst und einen Termin haben willst, dann kriegst du einen Mai, Juni ungefähr. Ja genau. Und die Schulen, die uns finden, die nutzen das wirklich sehr gern und sind da sehr rege. Es ist halt eben immer auch da so eine gewisse Geschichte, dass, ja, wie soll ich sagen, also die Lehrer müssen uns finden. Und es gibt halt eben immer ein paar, die sehr rührig sind und die irgendwie auch mal neue Wege gehen und Dinge ausprobieren. Und es gibt halt eben andere, die Unterricht machen, 08.15. So wie immer. Und ja, die kommen dann natürlich nicht zu uns. Aber ansonsten ist das halt eben der Punkt, wir versuchen uns direkt an die Schulen zu wenden. Also das heißt, gut, bei der Eröffnung haben wir natürlich jetzt halt eben einen Schulverteiler uns angelegt. Das heißt, wir haben wirklich alle Schulen der Region angeschrieben. Aber deswegen sind wir halt eben auch immer wieder regelmäßig bei Aktionen dabei. Wie jetzt auch vor zwei Jahren das Science-Shopping halt hier in Braunschweig. Das war also so ein verkaufsoffener Sonntag, der dann dem Thema Wissenschaft gewidmet war. Wo wir da mit einem Versuchsstand in die Stadt gegangen sind und wirklich guten Zulauf hatten. Und wo sich dann auch hinterher sehr viele darauf gemeldet haben, gesagt haben, Mensch, ich komm mit meiner Schulklasse hierher. Da haben wir einen Versuchsstand mitgenommen. Das ging um den sogenannten Freiflug. Das heißt, wir haben so ein paar Depron-Platten mitgenommen. Depron, das ist im Grunde so eine Art Styropor. Und die Schüler können dann mit Schablonen Flugzeugmodelle ausschneiden und das zusammenkleben. Und damit die dann ordentlich fliegen, müssen sie sich aber auch erstmal mit dem Thema der Schwerpunktlage beschäftigen. Und im Grunde damit den gleichen Weg durchlaufen, den schon die ersten Flugpioniere vor über 100 Jahren gegangen sind. Nämlich sich zu überlegen, was kann ich ableiten aus der Flugbahn meines Flugzeugs? Also was sehe ich daraus? Und das war ein Versuch, der echt viel Spaß bringt und wo die Jugendlichen sich da gerne mit beschäftigt haben. Und wo eben, wie gesagt, hinterher sehr viele darauf reflektiert haben.
An welche Lehrer wendet ihr euch? Also ich meine, wenn ihr euch an Schulen wendet, wenn ihr euch da an das Direktoriat oder geht man direkt so an die Fachlehrer ran? Welche Disziplinen werden da angesprochen?
Also im Prinzip wenden wir uns, naja, um sicher zu gehen, im Prinzip an alle. Also das heißt, wir wenden uns an die Schulleiter oder die Direktorien, aber dann vor allem schon an die Fachbereiche Physik, Naturwissenschaften, Technik, Mathe. Also das hat ja überall manchmal ein bisschen andere Namen. Und das ist natürlich schon halt unsere Hauptzielgruppe. Aber vom Prinzip her ist das so, dass die Schüler, die zu uns kommen, sind also jetzt nicht nur die, die sowieso schon Physik als Leistungskurs haben oder ein verstärktes naturwissenschaftliches Profil haben, sondern zu uns kommen ganz normale Schulklassen, wo halt einfach die ganz normale Verteilung dabei ist, auch was das Interesse betrifft. Also man hat im Grunde in jeder Schulklasse ein oder zwei Schüler dabei. Das sind echte Quacks. Die haben irgendwie total viel Lust und Spaß daran und auch schon ganz viel Vorwissen über diese Luftfahrtthemen. Und dann hat man halt eben ein oder zwei Schüler dabei, denen das ehrlich gesagt links und rechts ein Meter am allerwertesten vorbeigeht. Und dazwischen hat man das ganz große Mittelfeld und die kann man begeistern, wenn man es gut macht. Und ich glaube, das gelingt uns hier in der Regel. Zumindest ist das das Feedback, was wir von den Schülern eben auch bekommen. Und insofern wenden wir uns im Grunde an alle. Einfach weil es uns eben darum geht, ins Bewusstsein zu bringen, dass es halt eben andere Berufe gibt als Mediziner oder Rechtsanwalt. Und weil wir halt einfach das mal aufzeigen wollen und einfach Begeisterung wecken wollen. Und ganz häufig ist es ja auch so, dass man sich erst für Dinge interessieren kann, wenn man von ihnen Kenntnis hat, wenn man weiß, dass es das gibt. Und deswegen ist es uns halt einfach wichtig, dass nach einem Schulbesuch nicht 30 neue Ingenieure vor der Tür stehen. Das wissen wir auch. Aber das ist das, was gut funktioniert.
Das ist eine langfristige Investition in gewisser Art.
Also man findet natürlich, oder andersrum, es gibt mittlerweile auch eine wissenschaftliche Studie zum Effekt von den DLR-Schoollabs. Und die sich eben wirklich nur mit unseren Schoollabs beschäftigt haben. Und die haben ganz klar gezeigt, dass man natürlich einen Anstieg im Kurzfristinteresse hat. Ganz klar, du bist irgendwo gewesen, hast dich mit einem spannenden Thema irgendwie auseinandergesetzt und bist Feuer und Flamme und sagst so, Mensch, da möchte ich gerne mehr wissen. Und kurzfristig ist da auf jeden Fall ein Anstieg im Interesse festzustellen. Und das ebbt natürlich dann auch bei einigen halt eben über die Zeit wieder ab, das ist ganz klar. Aber interessanterweise haben wir auch festgestellt, dass das selbst im Langzeitrahmen sozusagen eine Erhöhung des Interesses festzustellen ist. Also das war auch einer, der jetzt Schoollableiter ist in Berlin, der hat diese Studie angefertigt, als das eben noch nicht war. Das war seine Dessertation und der konnte das ganz klar zeigen. Das war sehr spannend.
Ich freu mich gerade, dein Hintergrund ist ja auch eher technischer Natur, wenn ich das richtig verstehe. In dem Moment, wo man aber jetzt hier versucht, Wissen zu vermitteln, ist das ja nicht nur eine technische Aufgabe, sondern im Prinzip auch eine pädagogische Aufgabe. Wie geht denn das zusammen?
Also ich mein, wenn man das macht, dann muss man natürlich ganz klar ein Interesse dafür mitbringen. Dann muss man Lust dazu haben. Und bei mir kommen jetzt vielleicht verschiedene Dinge zusammen. Nämlich zum einen komme ich erstmal aus einem Bereich, der hier klassisch bei uns gar nicht vertreten ist. Also wir haben beim DLR natürlich auch ein paar Meteorologen, aber die sitzen dann in der Regel in Oberpfaffenhofen und machen Fernerkundung. Oder beschäftigen sich halt mit Wettererforschung aus dem Alt über Satelliten. Das ist Fernerkundung. Hier in Braunschmark haben wir sie eher selten. Das heißt, ich hab natürlich eben sowieso schon Zugang zu diesem Thema, einfach weil ich aus einem Bereich komme, wo ich das klassisch so nicht studiert hab. Ich hab halt Physik studiert, letztendlich als im Grundstudium. Und das ist halt die Verbindung. Und die Physik ändert sich ja nicht. Und insofern musste ich mir also selber einen Zugang zu dem Thema schaffen, aus einer ganz anderen Sichtweise heraus. Und das zweite ist natürlich, was mich auch wahnsinnig motiviert, dass ich eben tatsächlich als Frau hier in einem Bereich arbeite, der im Wesentlichen immer noch von Männern dominiert ist. Und auch da hab ich dann natürlich andere Blickwinkel. Und das ist halt was, was mir einfach wahnsinnig viel Spaß bringt, das eben an Jugendliche weiterzugeben, bzw. denen halt irgendwie einfach das zu vermitteln, dass Physikkent da in dem Sinne kein Geschlecht und kein Alter. Und man kann es lernen. Und das ist eine Sache, die kann sogar Spaß bringen.
Jetzt wird ja, also konkret sieht es so aus, nachdem man sich mit den Schulen quasi, also in dem Moment, wo man quasi Werbe gemacht hat oder Kontakt hergestellt hat, dann äußern die Lehrer Interesse, mit einer Klasse vorbeizukommen. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie viele kommen dann auf einmal?
Also es kommt immer eine ganze Schulklasse auf einmal.
Eine komplette Klasse.
Genau.
Was ist das so heutzutage im Schnitt?
Oh, das kann schwanken. Also die jüngeren Jahrgänge sind eher größer besetzt. Das heißt, da können auch schon mal 32 Schüler kommen. Und wenn jetzt ein Physik-Leistungskurs kommen, dann sind es halt auch nur noch 12 oder 10. Aber wir sind da, also da sind wir wirklich komplett Dienstleister. Wir richten uns nach dem, was gewünscht und gewollt ist. Und das Tolle bei uns ist, wir haben halt eben selber ein paar Lehrer mitangestellt, beziehungsweise also arbeiten wir uns im Labor mit. Und die halten dann auch den Kontakt zu den Lehrern der besuchenden Schulklasse, sprechen das Programm mit denen ab oder geben denen Empfehlungen darüber, was man bei uns machen kann.
Also mal 10, mal 30, wie teilt sich das dann auf? Ich hab jetzt eben auch ein bisschen mal reingeschnuppert, da waren das ja also mehrere Gruppen.
Ja, genau. Das ist das, was wir immer machen. Wenn eine Schulklasse zu uns kommt, die kommen bei uns an, bekommen einen kleinen Überblick erst mal über das DLR Braunschweig. Also ich meine, die sollen schon wissen letztendlich, wo sie jetzt hier sind, mit welchen Themen wir uns beschäftigen. Bekommen dann einen Überblick über das Programm, also was sie erwartet über den Tag. Und dann teilen wir sie auf in kleine Gruppen. Das sind eigentlich in der Regel so vier bis fünf Schüler. Die bekommen dann jeder einen Betreuer an die Hand und dann durchlaufen die halt eben verschiedene Versuchsstationen. Wo sie dann nach einer kurzen Einführung halt eben selbstständig anfangen können zu experimentieren. Und das funktioniert halt einfach eben richtig gut. Weil in diesen kleinen Gruppen im Grunde jeder gefordert ist und jeder direkt angesprochen wird. Und man also sehr schnell wirklich sehr persönlichen Kontakt aufbauen kann. Und man merkt das auch immer wieder, dass die Schüler, auch die Betreuer, das sind ja alles Studenten, also meistens Studenten, dass da auch viele Gespräche entstehen. Darüber, wie die Studenten zu ihrem Studium gekommen sind, was man dafür braucht. Also insofern, das ist genau das, was wir wollen. Wir wollen mit den Jugendlichen sprechen.
Genau, das ist mir nämlich auch aufgefallen, dass die Leute, die die Gruppen jetzt betreuen, jetzt nicht so die klassischen Lehrer sind, sondern auch markiert sind als Student, mit so einem kleinen Namensschildchen. Und da recht engagiert so aus ihrem Feld heraus berichtet haben.
Das sind Studenten hier bei uns von der TU Braunschweig. Und die habe ich angeschrieben letztendlich über einen der Professoren. Da hat halt ein Studentenverteiler, weil die an der Uni natürlich auch immer mal Informationen zirkulieren müssen. Und da habe ich damals einen Stellengesuch hingeschrieben, dass ich halt eben Studenten brauche, die Lust und Laune haben, hier bei uns im Labor zu arbeiten. Und dann haben sich eben auch gleich eine ganze Anzahl gemeldet. Und es funktioniert wirklich toll, weil die Studenten, die jetzt bei mir sind, viele arbeiten selber auch sowieso privat noch in der Jugendbetreuung. Also sei es, dass sie in Sportgruppen aktiv sind oder in kirchlichen Verbänden, was auch immer. Und im Grunde verbinden die hier bei uns im Labor einfach das, was sie machen wollen, mit dem, was sie sowieso tun.
Ja, man kann schon hören, dass man hier sich in einem technischen Bereich befindet, unklare Einstreueffekte von Telefonen, die nicht zu sehen sind. Wir skirren hier leider ein bisschen die Aufnahme. Aber nochmal zu den Studenten. Also ist das jetzt so eine feste Gruppe, die sich jetzt gefunden hat? Oder gibt es da am laufenden Meter neuen Bedarf?
Also wir haben schon immer mal neuen Bedarf. Leider muss ich fast sagen, weil natürlich die Studenten nur begrenzt studieren. Auch die werden ja irgendwann fertig oder wollen fertig werden. Was ich immer sehr bedauere, was man natürlich nicht verwehren kann. Und insofern, also die Einarbeitungszeiten dauern bei uns schon relativ lange, weil wir haben halt eben zehn Experimente im Labor. Bis man die so beherrscht, geht ein bisschen Zeit dahin. Insofern versuche ich natürlich immer, die Studenten auch so lang wie möglich zu halten. Das heißt, wir haben Studenten, die also mindestens sechs Monate bleiben sie alle, weil darunter stelle ich eigentlich niemanden ein. Aber wir haben auch noch Studenten aus der ersten Stunde. Das heißt, die sind jetzt seit über zwei Jahren bei uns.
Das heißt, das ist dann auch schon ein eingespieltes Team und man kommt auch mit größeren Klassen da problemlos klar.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und das liegt aber auch daran, dass wir ja bei uns im Labor halt eben auch noch die Lehrer haben. Und das ist halt eine Sache, wo sich das Land Niedersachsen besonders hervortut. Niedersachsen ordnet nämlich Lehrkräfte ab in solchen Einrichtungen wie unsere. Insgesamt sind sie, glaube ich, dieses Jahr mit 16 Stellen dabei. Das ist wirklich viel im Bundesdurchschnitt. Also in Nordrhein-Westfalen interessiert sich da, glaube ich, gar nicht viel. Da gibt es, glaube ich, null. Und in Bayern zwei. Oder umgekehrt. Und wir haben also eben eine von diesen 16 Stellen bekommen, die ist verteilt worden auf vier Personen, die jetzt halt eben ihrerseits jeder ungefähr ein bis anderthalb Tage im Labor sind. Das heißt, wir haben im Grunde an jedem Tag der Woche auch eben eine Lehrkraft da. Und davon profitieren wir alle, weil wir natürlich von den Experimenten her, die wissenschaftliche Expertise haben wir hier vor Ort. Das ist nicht der Punkt. Aber die Frage ist ja immer, wie breche ich denn irgendwas so runter, dass es auch ein Schüler versteht, bzw. dass er es ankoppeln kann an den Unterricht, an das, was er nämlich schon gelernt hat. Wie bringt das dahin? Und da sind die Lehrkräfte bei uns ganz wichtig, weil die nämlich halt eben genau diese Verbindung schaffen. Und die Lehrkräfte schulen letztendlich auch unsere Studenten. Und von daher funktioniert das Ganze so gut.
Das heißt, es gibt auch so quasi eine Co-Finanzierung durch das Land. Dadurch, dass diese Stelle mitgestellt wird.
Das ist tatsächlich genau der einzige Teil, der vom Land oder von extern übernommen wird. In diesem Fall vom Land Niedersachsen. Der Rest oder die übrigen oder die Schoollabs werden als solches komplett vom DLR finanziert. Das ist dadurch, dass wir ja eben auch halbstaatlich sind sozusagen. Also uns zu 50 Prozent aus Steuermitteln finanzieren, ist das halt eben so ein Punkt, wo das DLR das letztendlich an die Allgemeinheit wieder zurückgibt.
Das ist ja eigentlich generell, glaube ich, gar keine schlechte Idee, dass man versucht, die etablierte Wissenschaftslandschaft auch mehr in die Schulen zu integrieren und umgekehrt. Gibt es da irgendeinen Trend oder andere Vorbilder, vielleicht auch im Ausland, wo das irgendwie anders gemacht wird?
Also das ist auf jeden Fall eine super Geschichte, dass es das gibt und ich wünschte, dass es das zu meiner Schulzeit schon gegeben hätte. Ich glaube, dann hätte ich mich vielleicht auch noch leichter mit dem ganzen getan. Ansonsten muss man dazu ganz klar sagen, was das Ausland betrifft, da sind wir der Vorreiter. Also in Deutschland gibt es mittlerweile alleine über Lernort Labor, LELA, das ist so eine Dachorganisation, da gibt es 300 angemeldete oder registrierte Schülerlabore. Das ist im Grunde im europäischen Ausland einmalig. In Europa weiß man im Grunde gar nicht, was das ist, ein Schülerlabor.
300 Schülerlabore, das schließt jetzt die DLR-Schoollabs mit ein, aber auch andere.
Ja, also da findet man verschiedene Trägerschaften, also sei es, dass Museen sich zum Beispiel da engagieren im Bereich Pädagogik, dass sie also Angebote haben, die man vielleicht jetzt nicht als Schülerlabor bezeichnet, aber die halt eben Angebote für Jugendliche sind, Wissen zu vermitteln. Dann findet man sowas im Industriebereich, aber der stärkste Bereich ist da tatsächlich bei den Universitäten und Forschungseinrichtungen. Das sind eigentlich die, die die meisten davon stellen, einfach weil die halt eben da noch am ehesten bereit sind, auch das Geld in die Hand zu nehmen. Oder es vielleicht auch am ehesten finanzieren können, aufgrund der Struktur. Also in privater Hand gibt es da nur recht wenige. Aber wie gesagt, da sind wir hier in Deutschland wirklich sehr, sehr gut dran und sehr gut bestökt im europäischen Ausland. Da sind wir jetzt halt mit dabei oder versuchen eben jetzt auch uns über europäische Projekte damit reinzuschalten, sodass man halt eben versucht, jetzt auch die Nachwuchsförderung auch im europäischen Ausland mit aufzubauen. Weil auch dort ist der Nachwuchsmangel. Aber das Problem ist irgendwie, ist da manchmal so ein bisschen der Trend, jeder braucht den Nachwuchs, aber bitte schön der andere möcht's doch machen. Und damit kommen wir jetzt nicht so richtig weiter.
Wenn sich jetzt hier die Klassen eingefunden haben, und es teilt sich jetzt so auf, und die werden dann so ein bisschen an die Hand genommen, was vermittelt man denn dann konkret? Also was passiert denn tatsächlich in den Laboren?
Also was wir versuchen zu vermitteln, das ist eigentlich eine Mischung aus mehreren Dingen. Wir versuchen zum einen erstmal da anzukoppeln, wo der Schüler gerade ist, sei es von seinem Kenntnisstand oder auch von seinem Erfahrungsstand her. Bei unserem Versuchsstand über die Bahnsicherungstechnik. Es sind alle Schüler schon mal Bahn gefahren, und jeder hat sich bestimmt schon mal darüber gewundert, über bestimmte Anzeigen im Display, dass es da halt zu Verspätungen kommt wegen Störungen im Bahnablauf, oder wie es dann heißt. Und das sind so Dinge, die bei uns vermittelt werden. Oder wo wir uns dann reinklinken sozusagen und daran versuchen, eigentlich die Technik zu vermitteln. Aber wie gesagt, es ist auch einfach so ein bisschen das gesamte Umfeld, was wir versuchen zu vermitteln. Eben, dass die Arbeit oder die Versuche letztendlich auch eine Arbeit repräsentieren, nämlich die von Wissenschaftlern und Ingenieuren. Und dass das durchaus Spaß machen kann, dass das halt eben nicht immer nur eine Arbeit irgendwo im stillen Kämmerlein ist, sondern dass das ganz viel Austausch bedeutet und Diskussionen mit anderen Wissenschaftlern. Dass das spannende Versuche oder Experimente mit beinhaltet. Und einfach mal eben dieses Bild aufzubrechen, was man so hat, wenn man an den Physiker oder den Ingenieur denkt.
Wir können es ja vielleicht noch ein bisschen konkreter schildern. Es gibt da einen großen Raum. Da sind verschiedene Laborbereiche abgebildet. Es handelt sich jetzt nicht um einen Frontalunterricht mit Hallo, ich erzähle euch jetzt mal was über Wissenschaft. Sondern es wird dann wirklich konkret gemacht. Wenn man jetzt über die Bahntechnik redet, da fahren dann auch wirklich Züge. Natürlich im H0-Maßstab. Aber man hat im Prinzip eine komplette Bahnlandschaft mit Signalen und Pippa-Po-Steuersoftware. Man muss jetzt selber anfangen, Programme zu entwickeln. Was gibt es noch außer der Bahn?
Wir haben einen großen Versuchsraum, der ist gestaltet in acht kleine Bereiche. Zwei Versuche sind noch woanders untergebracht. Das heißt, dass die Schüler, die sich jeweils mit einem Versuch beschäftigen, nur diesen einen Versuch wahrnehmen. Da haben wir zum Beispiel einen Lotsenstand. Die Schüler werden damit vertraut gemacht, was die Arbeit eines Lotsen beinhaltet, der an einem Großflughafen sitzt. Genau. Wo jetzt Flugzeuge aus verschiedenen Richtungen auf den Flughafen zufliegen. In diesem Falle sind zwei Schüler die sogenannten Pseudopiloten. Pseudo deswegen, weil sie ja nicht wirklich fliegen. Jeder Pseudopilot hat dann gleich zehn Maschinen, die er kontrollieren muss. Diese 20 Maschinen kommen dann auf den Schirm von den beiden Fluglotsen. Die müssen dann mit den beiden Pseudopiloten kommunizieren. Genau wie wir beide jetzt hier über Kopfhörer und Headset und Intercom-Anlage, nur halt eben auf Englisch, aber mit der richtigen Phrasiologie. Und müssen dann halt eben die Anweisung geben für die richtige Höherichtung und Geschwindigkeit, damit dann die Flugzeuge sicher und am besten auch noch mit dem richtigen Sicherheitsabstand auf der Landebahn dann nachher wirklich ankommen.
Man sitzt dann auf einer richtigen Simulationssoftware, die genauso aussieht, wie das ein Fluglotse auch hat.
Das ist ein Versuchsstand, der hat bis bevor wir das Labor eröffnet haben in dem Institut gestanden für Flugführung. Und da haben die halt ihre Projekte dran gefahren. Das sind dann zum Beispiel Projekte, wo die halt eben wirklich die Anflugverfahren auf Großflughäfen optimieren oder neue Verfahren ausprobieren. Also in dem Fall, ich hab das mal mit beobachtet, da haben die versucht, Frankfurt zu simulieren mit Anflügen aus neun verschiedenen Richtungen. Und dann sitzen in einem Nebenraum, da sitzen dann nicht nur zwei Pseudopiloten, sondern gleich zehn. Und die haben halt eben auch nicht nur zehn Flugzeuge auf dem Schirm, sondern gleich 100. Und dann werden zwei Fluglotsen eingeladen von der DFS. Also von der Deutschen Fluglossensicherung. Oder Deutschen Flugsicherung, Entschuldigung. Und dann sitzen die halt eben genau vor diesen Konsolen, die wir jetzt halt auch haben, und sitzen da einen ganzen Tag dran und machen sich nebenbei Notizen und schreiben auf, was ihnen da dran auffällt, ob das gut funktioniert, wo es vielleicht Konflikte gegeben hat und so weiter. Und wenn die Fluglotsen dann das Ganze so abgespeckt haben oder die Flüge so weit reduziert haben, dass die dann nur noch so 20 Maschinen auf dem Schirm haben, das was unsere Schüler als Staatsszenario bekommen, dann sind die Fluglotsen, die echten, schon nicht mehr ausgelastet und fangen an, sich über ihre Erlebnisse am Wochenende zu unterhalten. Also daran sieht man dann schon, was die Fluglotsen wirklich für ein Nervenkostüm haben und was da gefordert wird.
Das ist wirklich ein interessantes Berufsbild. Ich habe den Mädchen, die da gerade am Werkeln waren, so ein bisschen über die Schulter geschaut. Das war natürlich eine helle Aufregung, überall so kleine weiße Punkte. Man wusste, die fliegen jetzt irgendwie gleich alle an denselben Punkt. Und da merkte man, dass man dann schon sehr in die Realität gerissen wird. So was man sonst auch als selbstverständlich ansehen kann. Man geht zum Flughafen und so, hier Boarding-Pass, man setzt sich da rein, warum geht es denn jetzt hier nicht los? Und so können wir jetzt nicht endlich mal starten. Das ist so die Sichtweise, die man halt kennt. Aber die Sichtweise oben auf dem Tower, dass man tausend blinkende Punkte da hat und auch eine unglaubliche Konzentration aufbringen muss, um das eben alles parallel zu machen. Also klar, ein geübter Flugplotzer, der denkt sich so, was nur 100 Flugzeuge und so, gibt es sonst keine Herausforderung. Aber wenn man dann erst mal nur so fünf koordinieren muss, dann rotiert man natürlich schon ziemlich schnell, um diese ganzen Protokolle dann abarbeiten zu können.
Also das ist auch wirklich ganz spannend und das bringt den Schülern auch wahnsinnig viel Spaß. Das ist im Grunde der einzige Punkt. Oder das ist eigentlich mit der wichtigste Punkt. Wir versuchen bei allen anderen, die Realität abzubilden. Und das ist auch genau das, wo wir halt, und deswegen war der Satz mit das Einzige angefangen, wo wir im Grunde humorlos waren. Das ist, wenn zwei Schüler anfangen, 11. September zu spielen. Und sagen, so jetzt machen wir mal den programmierten Crash. Das ist das Einzige, da ist dann das Szenario sofort zu Ende. Da sind wir absolut humorlos, weil für uns bedeutet jedes Flugzeug 300 Leben. Und damit wird nicht gespielt, auch nicht im Labor. Aber diese Ideen sind Gott sei Dank nur sehr selten. Die meisten Schüler haben halt da einen ganz spielerischen Angang, aber auch mit sehr viel Ernst bei der Sache und wahnsinnig viel Spaß, weil die einfach das begreifen, dass es eine Wahnsinnsgelegenheit ist, halt wirklich mal Dinge auszuprobieren und so real zu bekommen. Ich meine, das ist eine Geschichte, die hat man auch nicht mehr zu Hause auf dem Rechner, sondern da kriegt man wirklich mal einen echten Einblick ins Leben und vielleicht in einen Bereich, der einen dann vielleicht später doch interessiert.
Was man auch nicht so ohne Weiteres zu Hause rumstehen hat, ist so ein riesiges Hubschrauber-Modell, der da so ein bisschen fest montiert ist. Also er fliegt nicht durch die Gegend, sondern ist fest.
Genau, das ist unser T-Rex. Der heißt so, den gibt es also tatsächlich noch. Das ist ein Hubschrauber-Modell, der bei uns ein paar technische Änderungen bekommen hat. So ein echtes Schlag- und Schwenkgelenk. Dem Fachmann wird es was sagen. Das sind so bestimmte Aufhängungen für die Rotorblätter. Der wird in der Tat, der fliegt nirgendwo mehr hin. Der ist festgebunden. Der ist auf einer Vertikal, über eine Stange, auf einer Personenwaage montiert. Wenn man über die Rotorblätter Auftrieb produziert, dann zieht der wirklich nach oben. Und über die Waage kann man das messen. Der Waage ist ja letztendlich egal, ob ich mich drauf stelle oder ob ich dran ziehe. Das ist nur eine Frage des Vorzeichens. Insofern bekommen da die Schüler einen ganz tollen Einblick, wie beim Hubschrauber der Auftrieb produziert wird, wie ein Hubschrauber fliegt, was der Pilot alles können muss, wofür der seine Hände und Füße gebraucht, weil Hubschrauber fliegen ist verdammt kompliziert. Und das sieht man da sehr schnell.
Dann gibt es auch noch so einen großen Windkanal, der ist ganz neu.
Ja, das ist unser neustes Baby sozusagen. Da sind wir noch ein bisschen dran, aber das kommt jetzt. Das ist ein Windkanal, der im Grunde, wir versuchen da einfach mehrere Dinge dran zu machen. Das heißt, wir können ganze Autos da reinstellen, also Modellautos natürlich. Und versuchen da eben anzukoppeln bei den Schülern einfach auch wieder aus der täglichen Erfahrungswelt. Warum hat das eine Auto einen Heckscheibenwischer und das andere eben nicht? Oder wenn ich eine Lokomotive reinstelle, wie verhält sich die Strömung drum rum? Wann legt sie sich wieder an, an die restliche Bahn? Wie entstehen beim Flugzeug die Wirbelschleppen? Wo lösen überall Wirbel ab? Warum ist das so? Oder wie ändert sich der Auftrieb von dem Profil einer Tragfläche? Also man kann da ganz spannende Dinge machen. Wir können Kräfte messen. Wir können Strömungen einfach sichtbar machen. Das ist also insofern einfach faszinierend und eben auch sehr anschaulich und auch für Jüngere. Für ganz Kleine haben wir halt ein Tragflügelprofil, da kann man mit dem Arm so reingreifen und kann das in die Strömung halten, sodass man dann halt eben Auftrieb und Widerstand eben direkt am eigenen Leib erfahren kann. Und das sind halt eben immer so die eindruckvollsten Experimente mit, die ganz einfach sind, aber wo man wirklich die Kräfte mal merkt.
Du hast es ja gerade angesprochen, die Schüler haben jetzt nicht immer das gleiche Alter. Es ist nicht so, dass man jetzt nur auf eine einzige Klasse geht. Was war nochmal der Range?
Wir fangen an bei Klasse 5 bis Klasse 13.
Klasse 5. Da sind sie ja noch eher jung. Wie passt man sich da an? Was unterscheidet dann die Vorgehensweise?
Vom Prinzip her ist es so, dass die 5 Klessler bei uns im Grunde so ein bisschen mehr tun als spielen. Wir versuchen da einfach sehr spielerisch ranzugehen. Du hast es vorhin schon einmal gesagt, was wir nicht machen wollen, ist Frontalunterricht. Wir sind keine Schule. Wir sind auch keine Verlängerung der Schulbank, sondern wir beschäftigen uns hier mit dem realen Leben, mit spannenden Forschungsthemen. Das versuchen wir halt altersgerecht rüberzubringen. Auch dafür haben wir eben unsere Lehrer. Das heißt, wir haben für jeden Versuchstand verschiedene Konzepte. Eben, dass wir mit fünf Klesslern was anderes machen als mit neun Klesslern oder mit zwölf Klesslern. Demzufolge gestaltet sich der Tag auch immer ein bisschen anders. Das heißt, die fünf Klessler kommen morgens um neun und die gehen mittags um eins auch wieder nach Hause. Während wenn jetzt ein Physik-Leistungskurs kommt, die sind dann den ganzen Tag bei uns, machen entsprechend mehr Experimente und werden da halt ein bisschen mehr gefordert und werden da im Grunde schon ein bisschen an die Wissenschaft herangeführt. Weil wir da ja schon denen auch so ein bisschen einfach was aufzeigen wollen und mitgeben wollen. Aber auch da ist uns das immer wichtig, dass die Spaß haben. Weil ich meine, man lernt nichts und man will auch nichts weiter lernen, wenn man da keinen Spaß hat und wenn man da keine Faszination erlebt. Und das ist das, was uns halt wichtig ist da dran. Also in der Regel ja. Das ist zumindest das, was uns immer wieder reflektiert wird. Jeder Klassenbesuch endet damit, dass wir einen Fragebogen verteilen und dass wir das abfragen. Wie war das Interesse an dem Versuch? Hat es dich vorher interessiert? Bist du gut betreut worden? Hast du das Gefühl, dass du es wirklich verstanden hast? Das sind so die Sachen, die wir wissen wollen. Wir fragen nach Verbesserungsvorschlägen. Einfach damit wir uns verbessern können und gucken können, gibt es irgendwo Probleme? Taucht irgendwas regelmäßig auf? Also wenn jetzt mehrfach der gleiche Verbesserungsvorschlag kommt, dann wär es mal eine gute Gelegenheit, darüber nachzudenken. Bislang ist da aber noch nichts gekommen. Also bislang haben wir da tatsächlich Bestnoten. Und das ist was, was mich auch sehr freut. Und wo ich halt einfach merke, dass die Begeisterung, die ich dafür habe, auch offenbar bei anderen ankommt.
Aber jetzt natürlich die Frage, wie lange hält sich das? Wir hatten ja vorhin schon über so kurz- und mittelfristige Effekte gesprochen. Ich frage mich jetzt vor allem gerade, inwieweit es dann noch Kontakt mit den Lehrern gibt. Also gibt es dann Rückmeldungen von den Lehrern, ob die in irgendeiner Form auch eine Auswirkung auf ihre normale Schultätigkeit feststellen können? Oder ist das jetzt ein bisschen zu weit hergeholt?
Nein, das ist eigentlich genau das, was man ja immer wieder versucht zu festzulegen oder eigentlich zu untermauern. Wir fragen uns natürlich auch, haben diese Schülerlaboren Effekt? Weil ich meine, wir pumpen da wirklich eine Menge Geld rein. Und dann am Ende des Tages möchte man natürlich schon auch wissen, kommt da was bei rüber. Bei den Schülern ist es so, in der Regel kommt ein Schüler im Laufe seiner Schullaufbahn nur ein einziges Mal zu uns, wenn er Glück hat. Wenn er kein Glück hat, dann war er nie bei uns. Insofern ist es den Schülern im Grunde mit der Entwicklung noch relativ egal. Bei den Lehrern ist das so eine Sache. Die kommen im Zweifelsfall mehrfach, weil die ihre Klassen immer wieder begleiten. Und wir versuchen da schon, die Versuche auch einfach immer weiterzuentwickeln, eben genauso wie die Forschungsinstitute oder die Forschungsthemen, versuchen wir eben auch dabei zu bleiben, um auch weiterhin die neuesten Sachen zu präsentieren. Wir wollen ja hier auch keine Ladenhüter von vor Anno Dunomal haben. Und insofern, was auch noch mal bei dieser wissenschaftlichen Studie damals rausgekommen ist, ist, dass tatsächlich über einen einzigen Besuch beim DLR-Schoollab eine ganze Menge gerissen werden kann. Man konnte nachweisen, dass Schüler, die sich nie dafür interessiert haben, hinterher wirklich in solche Berufe gegangen sind, aufgrund des Kontakts mit dem DLR. Das war eine Studie, die hat Fragebögen verteilt einmal kurz vor dem Besuch, am Tag des Besuches, sechs Wochen nach dem Besuch und ich glaube ein Jahr nach dem Besuch. Und insofern konnte man das dann tatsächlich...
Also das war jetzt sozusagen für Schüler, die auch schon am Ende ihrer Schulzeit standen.
Genau und das war ein Rücklauf von, ich glaube, 764 Schülern oder so was. Also es war tatsächlich eine Stichprobe, die da schon so groß ist, dass man da wirklich ein paar harte Zahlen sozusagen daraus ableiten konnte.
Bringen denn die Lehrer auch so Themenwünsche mit ein? Also steht man da so im Verbund, dass sich das jetzt nicht nur aus dem Institutsleben hier definiert?
Also an Versuchsständen nein, das geben wir vor. Weil wir da ganz klar den Anspruch haben, eben wie gesagt, unsere Themen darstellen zu wollen. Und weil wir auch letztendlich, ja wie gesagt, wir verstehen uns nicht als Verlängerung der Schulbank. Wir können und wollen nicht das auffangen, was an der Schulpolitik oder in den Schulen schiefläuft. Dafür sind wir nicht da. Aber was wir halt tun, ist, dass ganz häufig Lehrer zu uns kommen und sagen, Mensch, ich hab gerade eine Projektwoche. Ich möchte was machen zum Thema Mobilität oder sicherer Verkehr oder Aerodynamik. Warum fliegt ein Flugzeug? Dann sind das Sachen, wo wir uns einklinken und wo wir dann halt eben gezielt Versuche vorbereiten, die sich dann oder speziell mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzen.
Das heißt, ihr seid dann auch vor Ort in der Schule oder geht es darum, Materialien zu erarbeiten oder nur Vorschläge zu machen für den normalen Unterricht?
Das sind dann Vorschläge für den Besuch hier im Labor. Das sind dann schon Sachen, die sich bei uns abspielen nach wie vor. Die müssten dann schon zu uns kommen. Aber wir versuchen dann halt eben darüber anzukoppeln und eben dann diese Themenwünsche mit zu berücksichtigen, oder?
Aber wäre das nicht grundsätzlich auch so ein Weg, in dem man gehen könnte? Weil das große Ziel ist ja Interesse schaffen für Wissenschaft. Interesse schaffen für die Berufe und einfach da auch grundsätzlich vielleicht einen langsamen Wertewandel auch mindestens mit zu beeinflussen. Jetzt kann sich das hier in diesem Schoollab natürlich abspielen. Das sind sozusagen die idealen Bedingungen. Nicht wahr? Raus aus der Schule etc. Aber man wird natürlich primär von dem geprägt, was täglich auf einen niedersinkt. Gibt es da auch Bestrebungen, jetzt vielleicht auch außerhalb der Schoollabs sozusagen mehr von diesem wissenschaftlichen Know-how auch zurück in die Schulen zu tragen oder auch dem pädagogischen Wissenschafts-Know-how in die Schulen zu tragen?
Also auch da sind wir dran. Wir versuchen da zum einen eben über die Lehrerfortbildung was zu erreichen. Also das heißt, wir bieten Lehrerfortbildung an, manchmal zu bestimmten Themen, manchmal auch zu unseren Versuchen. Aber versuchen den Lehrern halt letztendlich Dinge mitzugeben, womit sie ihren eigenen Unterricht anreichern können, sodass sie halt eben einfach wirklich einen spannenden Physikunterricht machen können, auch ohne DLR-Schoollab. Das heißt, mit einem Besuch bei uns kann es vielleicht noch besser werden, aber die Lehrer sollen in die Lage gesetzt werden, halt eben bei sich einfach einen spannenden Unterricht zu machen. Zum anderen ist der Trend eben tatsächlich Modelle zu schaffen, dass man halt eben mit Versuchen auch an die Schulen geht. Da gab es auch bei uns eine Idee, dass es aber noch in der Schwebe sozusagen, weil das natürlich auch einfach personell sehr aufwendig wird. Und wir haben eben jetzt auch die Labore. Und zum anderen Lehrer in die Lage zu versetzen. Ja, also wir sind auch dabei, gerade Unterrichtsmaterialien zu entwickeln. Also es wird demnächst was zum Thema Energie erscheinen. Und ich selbst arbeite zusammen mit einem Kollegen an Unterrichtsmaterialien zum Thema Luftfahrt. Das sind dann Unterlagen, die werden an alle 4000 weiterführenden Schulen in Deutschland geschickt, wo halt eben diese Themen, also Luftfahrt, dann in dem Sinne aufgegriffen wird, dass man zum einen was lernt über Auftrieb und Kräfte und über Flugzeuge als solches und Ballonen und Zeppeline und Antriebe. Also rund um das Thema gespickt mit Informationen darüber, kleine Mitmach-Experimente oder eben für neugierige Dinge, die sie sich selber weiter recherchieren können im Internet oder kleine Aufgaben, die man mal durchspielen kann, um mal so überschlägig sich ein paar Sachen selbst auszurechnen auf eine einfache Weise. Das ist das, wo wir auch dran sitzen. Und wir arbeiten auch gerade da dran, Experimente aufzuschreiben, die dann auf unserer Internetseite DLR NEXT veröffentlicht werden, sodass sich dort auch Lehrer diese Experimente runterladen können, eben auch, um wieder den Physikunterricht aufzupeppen und was zu machen, was einfach auch dann sehr viel Praxisbezug hat.
Was ist das für ein Projekt?
Also DLR NEXT ist ein Jugendportal oder das ist das Jugendportal des DLR, was einfach neben den DLR School Labs noch existiert. Also die DLR School Labs sind ja wirklich eine ganz praktische Einrichtung zum Herkommen und Anfassen und Mitmachen. Wir haben natürlich auch Internetseiten, aber die sind halt eben mehr zur Vorabinformation oder hinterher nochmal so zum Gucken. Während DLR NEXT halt eben ein Portal ist, wo man wirklich ganz interaktiv viele Dinge machen kann, also halt sich verschiedene Themenbereiche reinlesen kann, arbeiten kann, wo man sich witzige Filme oder interessante Sachen angucken kann, mit Fragen konfrontiert wird. Was haben Schokolade und Dynamit gemeinsam? Oder wo steckt mehr Energie drin? Also wo man einfach auch mal mit Fragestellungen konfrontiert wird und mit ganz, ganz viel Informationen, die aber auf eine tolle Weise dargebracht sind. Also es bringt wahnsinnig viel Spaß, durch DLR NEXT mal durchzusurfen, weil es tolle Bilder gibt, tolle Filme und alle mit aktuellem Forschungsbezug. Also das ist wirklich eine spannende Geschichte.
Ist das auch Material, was so direkt für den Unterricht gedacht ist, oder ist es eher zur direkten Benutzung?
Also dann die Experimente, die dort veröffentlicht werden, die sind dann im Grunde für die Lehrer gedacht, um das wirklich mit den Schulen oder in den Schulen durchführen zu können. Aber diese Seiten als solches sind natürlich für die Jugendlichen, um wirklich mal sich ja mit oder sich Informationen beschaffen zu können über Dinge, die sich vielleicht interessiert und wo sie einfach mehr wissen wollen.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich hier viel über Luft- und Verkehrssysteme gesprochen, was ja gar nicht so im Mittelpunkt jetzt hier auch der Raumzeit-Serie steht. Aber es ist ja jetzt auch nicht das einzige School Lab, das haben wir ja schon gesagt, andere School Labs haben auch andere Schwerpunkte. Wie sind denn diese Schwerpunkte so bei den anderen School Labs verteilt?
Ja, bei Raumzeit bietet sich das natürlich an, über Raumfahrt zu sprechen. Das wäre dann zum Beispiel in Köln angesiedelt oder auch in Oberpfaffenhofen. Oberpfaffenhofen, ganz spannend, unser Satellitenkontrollzentrum. Ganz häufig haben die Schüler Gelegenheit, dort auch mit rein zu gucken. Dort sieht man dann wirklich die auf großen Leinwänden dargestellt, die Flugbahnen der Satelliten, wo sie sich gerade befinden und wie sie angesteuert werden können. In Berlin gibt es noch die Planetenforschung. Auch dort ist noch Verkehrsystemtechnik oder Verkehrstechnik das zweite große Thema. Wie vermeide ich Staus? In Köln sind wir bei der Raumfahrt, bei der Biologie angekommen, also Raumfahrtmedizin. Oder Einfluss von Schwerelosigkeit auf den Körper insgesamt. In Göttingen ist auch Aerodynamik, Strömungstechnik und Aeroelastik. Da geht es um Schwingungen, z.B. Schwingungen von Tragflügeln, Deformationen. Man sieht es schlecht, wenn man selber fliegt, aber die Tragflächen verbiegen sich oder biegen durch beim Fliegen. Da möchte man vorher gerne wissen, wie viel werden sie sich verbiegen, bei welchen Belastungen, weil es natürlich nicht zum Bruch kommen darf. Das sind Themen, die sich dort weitgehend damit beschäftigen. Dann haben wir in Bremen, wird demnächst noch eins eröffnet werden. Es gibt weitere Schülerlabore in Neustrelitz, in Lampolzhausen. Ich muss selber mal überlegen.
Es sind eine Menge. Lampolzhausen, da wo die Raketentechniker zu Hause sind, da hat sich hier die dritte Ausgabe von Raumzeit schon gewidmet. Ich bin auch schon mit Schülern, die bei den Schoollabs mit involviert waren, konkret in Köln schon mal zusammengekommen, im Rahmen meines Parabelfluges. Das war ja auch ein Thema bei der Sendung über Forschung in Schwerelosigkeit, wo Experimente konkret in dem Zusammenhang mit Biologie gemacht wurden und es dann eben auch tatsächlich sogar für zwei Schüler die Möglichkeit gab, mit beim Parabelflug dabei zu sein.
Ja, das ist toll. Darum beneide ich dich. Das ist eine Möglichkeit, die ich wahrscheinlich nicht haben werde, die ich aber wahnsinnig gerne hörte. Wenn es also hier beim DLR jemanden hört, der sich dafür interessiert, dann würde ich das an der Stelle sehr gerne unterbringen. Ich hätte auch noch ein paar tolle Ideen für Experimente für Schüler, die würde ich auch mitnehmen. Jetzt sind wir vom Thema abgekommen.
Ich wollte darauf hinaus, dass es auch etwas andere Modelle gibt, wie die Schüler konkret an dem wissenschaftlichen Prozess beteiligt werden. Parabelflug ist jetzt ein bisschen das Extrembeispiel. Das gibt es jetzt nicht überall. Aber letztlich ist es so, jedes GULAB findet da auch seinen eigenen Weg. Das hängt ja auch extrem vom Thema und an den beteiligten Instituten zusammen.
Das ist das Tolle bei uns, dass im Grunde auch jedes Schülerlabor anders funktioniert, andere Rahmenbedingungen hat, andere Dinge tut, was uns verbindet. Das sind eben die Schulbesuche und auch Schülerwettbewerbe. Das ist auch eine andere Form, wo wir versuchen, Schüler mit einzubinden. Das heißt, wir loben Wettbewerbe aus, wo Schüler aktiv irgendwas machen können, was dann von uns begutachtet wird, wo Preise verliehen werden. Wir engagieren uns bei Jugendforscht, wir engagieren uns bei anderen Stiftungen, denen wir dann Stipendien oder Praktika zukommen lassen. Wir versuchen, diese Einrichtung zu unterstützen und Dinge anzubieten, wo man als normaler Mensch, wie man immer meint, im Grunde keinen Bezug oder keinen Zugang dazu hat. Da versuchen wir, das weiterzugeben an entsprechende Schüler.
Inwiefern sind denn die Wissenschaftler hier aus den Instituten selbst an dem Prozess mit beteiligt?
Die sind zu einem großen Teil daran beteiligt. Natürlich nicht alle, aber aus jedem Institut gibt es ein oder zwei Wissenschaftler, die diese Versuche mit aufgebaut haben. Bevor das Schoollab eröffnet hat, haben wir geguckt, was sind die Themen, mit denen die Institute gerne wissenschaftlich repräsentiert werden wollen. Dann bin ich zusammen mit den Lehrern wieder über diese Experimente gegangen. Wir haben zusammen geguckt, wie kann man das Ganze so darstellen, dass ein Schüler eben auch Lust hat, sich damit zu beschäftigen. Man kann sich natürlich auch vorstellen, dass wir einige vielleicht sehr wissenschaftliche Aufbauten haben, aber wo ein Schüler am Ende sagt, ja, aber spannend ist das jetzt nicht unbedingt. Und da muss man halt eben natürlich das Ganze dann schon so ein bisschen so frisieren, sag ich mal. Dass es einfach Spaß bringt, dass es jemanden fasziniert. Und das hat sehr gut funktioniert. Also es gibt eine ganz tolle Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Instituten, also den Wissenschaftlern dort und uns im Schülerlabor.
Was sind denn so jetzt die Wünsche für die nahe Zukunft? Wie kann sich denn diese Schüler, Schule, Wissenschaft, Interaktion weiterentwickeln? Woran mangelt es und was muss betont werden?
Also ich wünsche mir einfach, dass das hier noch deutlich weitergeht. Einfach, dass es mehr Zulauf gibt, dass wir uns weiter vernetzen in der Region auch. Wir haben hier noch weitere Einrichtungen und Forschungseinrichtungen, Forschungsregionen. Da wünsche ich mir, dass es einfach eine gute Zusammenarbeit gibt, die es jetzt schon gibt. Aber das kann man eben auch noch weiter ausbauen, dass eben noch mehr Schüler von uns wissen, dass das bei den Schulen einfach eine regelmäßige Geschichte wird. Dass es halt eben nicht nur so ein, ja ich geh mal ins School Lab, sondern dass das halt eben eine Geschichte wird, die sich etabliert und die dann auch langfristig für beide Seiten planbar ist sozusagen. Und sich einfach so integriert auch in die Schulen hinein, dass das eine feste Größe wird. Und damit meine ich auch durchaus nicht nur die DLR School Lab, sondern einfach alle Einrichtungen, die es in dem Sektor gibt. Das muss eigentlich in meinen Augen ganz normal und ganz, ja, Tagesgeschäft auch in den Schulen sein, rauszugehen und jede Gelegenheit zu nutzen, um den Schülern Dinge aufzuzeigen, die sie in der Schule nicht sehen können.
Was kann man denn nicht sehen? Also geht es jetzt da konkret jetzt um die Mittel? Also dass man eben komplexer aufbauten Materialien haben muss? Oder ist es auch, dass so dieser wissenschaftliche Prozess als solcher in der Schule noch gar nicht abgebildet wird? Das ist immer so ein bisschen auch mein wages Empfinden gewesen, dass so wissenschaftliche Arbeit als solche, worauf es dabei ankommt, so in dem schulischen Lernen so gar nicht vermittelt wurde. Dass man auf einmal feststellt, dass es da auch einen Bereich gibt, in dem das ganze Lernen und das sich Wissen erarbeiten und vor allem auch dieses Wissen, sich mit anderen gemeinsam in so einem riesigen globalen Netzwerk zu erarbeiten, dass das etwas ist, was ich zumindest so aus der Schule heraus noch nicht unbedingt so mitbekommen habe.
Also das ist tatsächlich so, das fängt im Kleinen damit an, dass die Schüler eigentlich noch viel mehr lernen müssen, dass sie nicht für den Menschen vorne lernen, der da an der Tafel steht und ihnen sagt, dass sie das machen sollen, sondern dass sie wirklich für sich lernen. Und was das heißt, nämlich dass das jetzt gerade mal so ihr Rüstzeug ist, womit sie dann rausgehen, damit fängt es an. Es geht sicherlich weiter damit, dass man, also klar Experimentierstände, wie wir sie hier haben, das kann eine Schule nicht leisten. Aber dafür sind wir ja da. Also ich meine, das ist ja das, was sie sich hier angucken können. Aber deswegen sollte es eben auch genutzt werden. Aber es muss auch manchmal im Unterricht anders vermittelt werden oder anders aufgehangen werden. Also ich brauche nur an mein eigenes Meteorologiestudium zurückzudenken. Da war das so, wir haben Studenten gehabt im Erstsemester. Auf die Frage hin, warum sie Meteorologie studieren, kam ja, weil ich immer schon mal ins Fernsehen wollte. Und wenn man sich anguckt, wie viele Meteorologen dann tatsächlich im Fernsehen landen. Solange die einzigen Prozesse, die man über Meteorologie lernt, nämlich über die Ekliptik und die Jahreszeiten, solange das in der Schule im Erdkundeunterricht vermittelt wird, wo es überhaupt nicht hingehört, solange müssen wir uns nicht wundern. Das sind die Ansatzpunkte, wo ich denke, da ist jeder aufgerufen, von den Forschungseinrichtungen, von den Industriefirmen, von der Wirtschaft die Toren zu öffnen und die Schüler zu sich zu holen. Und denen genau diese Dinge darzustellen. Einfach, dass das auch am Meer anfängt zu leben. Bislang ist das ja einfach so, dass ein Physiker oder ein Ingenieur, was ich eingangs schon sagte, das sind irgendwie so abgehobene Gestalten, lebensunfähig verrierte Hemden.
Wissenschaft hat immer so ein bisschen diesen Nimbus des Langweiligen. Das verstört mich auch so ein bisschen, obwohl es ja eigentlich gar nicht so ist.
Ja, aber wenn man sich mal hier umguckt, dann stellt man fest, das ist gar nicht so. Das sind Leute wie du und ich. Und gut, ich bin vielleicht auch Wissenschaftler. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da auch rausfalle. Aber das ist genau das Ding. Wenn man sich dann mal mit den Leuten beschäftigt, dann stellt man fest, das ist gar nicht so. Aber das lernt man eben erst, wenn man wirklich hierherkommt. Und wenn man sich das angucken kann, wenn man die Gelegenheit wirklich nutzt.
Ja, das probieren wir ja hier auch bei Raumzeit herauszuarbeiten. Und ich kann nur bestätigen, von Gespräch zu Gespräch öffnet sich eigentlich immer wieder eine neue Tür, wo man sich denkt so, warum hat mir das vorher noch keiner erzählt? Manchmal ist man auch schon fast so ein bisschen ärgerlich, dass man sich so denkt, muss ich jetzt so lange warten? Das hätten wir ja auch schon vorher erschließen können, dass das ja ist. Weil ich denke, was wirklich wichtig ist, jungen Menschen mitzugeben, ist so dieses Eröffnen von Erkenntniswelten. Eigentlich dieser ganze wissenschaftliche Prozess und sowohl dieses Ich eröffne das mir selbst und meinem Verständnis, als eben auch in einer fortgeschrittenen wissenschaftlichen Arbeit. Ich eröffne es anderen und schaffe halt neues Wissen. Also Wissenschaft sozusagen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Auch eine unglaubliche Genugtuung und Erfüllung mit sich bringt. Und dass das schon mal auch ein Abenteuer für sich ist.
Also das ist hier mit Sicherheit was, glaube ich, jeden einzelnen Mitarbeiter hier in Braunschweig treibt. Also wir sind hier irgendwie alle wirklich begeistert von den Themen, mit denen wir das zu tun haben. Und ich habe selten so tolle Arbeitsbedingungen gehabt. Also ich meine, wir haben hier alle, und das gilt jetzt nicht nur für die Nachwuchsförderung, das gilt auch eben vor allen Dingen für die wissenschaftlichen Bereiche, dass wir haben hier mit dem Top-Level oder mit dem aktuellsten Stand der Wissenschaft und Technik zu tun. Man arbeitet immer an den neuesten Dingen, wo kein anderer irgendwie was mit zu schaffen hat. Man hat Wahnsinnsfreiheiten und Möglichkeiten, Dinge auszuprobieren. Und das bringt einfach wahnsinnig viel Spaß, wenn man da halt irgendwie Neigungen hat. Und das ist einfach nur das, was jeder Schüler für sich halt rauskriegen muss. Im Grunde, was ist so sein, was treibt ihn an und wie tickt er? Und da muss man halt seine Schiene finden. Und dass die auch vielleicht nicht immer ganz gerade ausgeht. Ich meine, dafür bin ich das beste Beispiel, dass ich ja halt eben auch über so einen Seiteneinstieg hierher gekommen bin und absolut, glaube ich, meine Profession gefunden habe sozusagen. Und das ist das, was ich eigentlich jedem Schüler irgendwie wünsche. So ein bisschen schon zu hören, drauf zu achten und rauszufinden, wer bin ich? Und wo habe ich wirklich Lust zu? Weil ich glaube, man kann nur da gut sein, wo man wirklich Spaß dran hat. Ich meine, dass man nicht nur Spaß hat am Job und nicht alles immer hunky-dory ist, das ist auch klar. Aber der überwiegende Teil sollte schon so sein. Und ich finde, das ist auch ein wahnsinniger Luxus, wenn man da was gefunden hat, was einen so treibt und was man dann auch machen kann. Dann ist es toll, wenn man es machen darf.
Ja, und wenn jetzt Schüler oder Lehrer ein bisschen Blut geleckt haben und vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen mitforschen wollen, dann schaut man wo nach, wo es die Schoollabs gibt.
Also entweder unter www.dlr.de Schoollab oder halt eben einfach unter Google mal DLR Schoollab eintasten und dann einen Standort dazu, sei es nun Braunschweig, Göttingen, Köln, Oberpfalzkenhofen, haben wir alle schon. Genau. Oder Telefonbruch anrufen. Also ja, alles genau. Brieftauben haben wir noch nicht gehabt. Würden wir auch versuchen, wenn es geht.
Ja, super. Danke. Ich denke, jetzt haben wir es ganz gut eingekreist. Ein Thema ein bisschen hier, aber auch nur ein bisschen außer der Reihe. Aber auch wichtig, denke ich, im Verständnis dieses gesamten Wissenschaftskomplexes, auch um einfach klarzumachen, dass das alles gar nicht so separat von allen zu sehen ist. Und dass es auch wichtig ist, dass eigentlich Wissenschaft sehr früh beginnen muss. Insofern, vielen Dank für die Ausführung.
Ja, ich danke, dass ich hier sein durfte bzw. dass du hier bei mir warst und dass ich Gelegenheit hatte, das alles so darzustellen. Also ich würde mich sehr freuen, wenn das rübergekommen ist, wenn es Menschen gibt, die wir damit erreicht haben und die sich da angesprochen fühlen.
Ja, ich denke, es ist alles rübergekommen. Ja, insofern, vielen Dank auch fürs Zuhören. Das war die 31. Ausgabe von Raumzeit, die wieder mal nicht die letzte bleiben wird. Und jetzt geht es hier auch wieder in schneller gewohnter Folge weiter mit frischen Themen, die ich natürlich jetzt erstmal nicht verrate. Aber wir begeben uns auf jeden Fall auch bald wieder noch mehr auf die Spur der Raumfahrt selbst. Trotzdem vielen Dank Anke und bis bald bei Raumzeit.